>>> GOOD EVENING.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
ASK YOURSELF THIS QUESTION
TONIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU SUPPOSE WOULD HAPPEN
IF YOU WENT INTO WORK ONE DAY
AFTER POSTING A VIDEO DEPICTING
YOURSELF MURDERING A CO-WORKER
AND BRANDISHING A SWORD AT THE
COMPANY CEO?
NOW, MOST OF US KNOW THE ANSWER,
WE'D BE FIRED.
MAYBE, REPORTED TO THE
AUTHORITIES.
POSSIBLY, EVEN ARRESTED,
PROSECUTED.
SADLY, TOO MANY WORKPLACES HAVE
SEEN TOO MANY ACTS OF DEADLY
VIOLENCE TO DO OTHERWISE, EXCEPT
APPARENTLY THIS ONE.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT IT.
AND IT'S NOT LIKE IT HASN'T BEEN
THE FOCAL POINT OF RAGE AND R
VIOLENCE BEFORE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE MEN AND WOMEN
WHO SERVE HERE HAVEN'T JUST HAD
A VERY RECENT LESSON IN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND OUTRIGHT THREATS GO
UNANSWERED.
YET, NOT ONLY IS ONE OF THE TWO
PARTIES HERE WITH RARE EXCEPTION
SINGULARLY UNINTERESTED IN EVEN
LOOKING INTO SUCH THINGS.
WE KNOW TONIGHT IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF THE BAD ACT IN
QUESTION COMES FROM SOMEONE THEY
ACTUALLY WORK WITH.
ARIZONA CONGRESSMAN PAUL GOSAR
IS HIS NAME.
HERE IS JUST A BRIEF PORTION --
THE ONLY ONE WE WILL SHOW -- OF
THE ANIME HE RECENTLY POSTED ON
TWITTER AND INSTAGRAM DEPICTING
HIM KILLING CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WITH A
SWORD, AND THEN SWINGING TWO
SWORDS AT PRESIDENT BIDEN.
♪
>> SO THAT'S PART OF IT.
THE CONGRESSMAN'S ANIMATED
FANTASY OF MURDERING A FELLOW
MEMBER OF CONGRESS AND MENACING
THE PRESIDENT AND THIS IS THE
CONGRESSMAN'S SISTER JENNIFER
TALKING ABOUT HER BROTHER.
>> THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I HAVE
TO OPENLY WONDER.
DOES HE HAVE TO ACT ON IT
HIMSELF BEFORE WE BELIEVE THAT
HE IS -- HE IS A SOCIOPATH.
WHERE IS THE ACCOUNTABILITY?
>> AS TO HER QUESTION, THE WHITE
HOUSE CONDEMNED THE VIDEO.
HOUSE SPEAKER PELOSI SAID
ATHLETES OF VIOLENCE AGAINST
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
MUST NOT BE TOLERATED.
AND KEVIN McCARTHY.
GUESS WHAT HE SAID.
NOTHING.
WE INVITED HIM ON THE PROGRAM AS
WELL BUT HEARD NOTHING BACK.
CONGRESSMAN GOSAR, WHO WE ALSO
INVITED ON TONIGHT, TWEETED OUT
A CARTOON RESPONSE EARLIER
TODAY.
THE MESSAGE SAYING IT'S A
CARTOON, RELAX.
THEN LATER, HE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT WHICH SAYS IN PART
THAT THE ANIME QUOTE DEPICTS THE
SYMBOLIC NATURE OF A BATTLE
BETWEEN LAWFUL AND UNLAWFUL
POLICIES AND IN NO WAY INTENDED
TO BE A TARGETED ATTACK AGAINST
REPRESENTATIVE CORTEZ OR MR.
BIDEN WHICH DOESN'T EVEN MAKE
SENSE BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT IT
IS.
IT'S A TARGETED ATTACK.
IT'S NOT INTERPRETATION.
YES, IT'S AN ANIME.
PERHAPS, THE RICHEST SENTENCE,
THOUGH, IN THIS ONE QUOTING
AGAIN A CHAOTIC AND LAWLESS WIND
IS BLOWING ACROSS OUR LAND.
HE'S NOT WRONG ABOUT THAT ONE.
JUST LISTEN TO A PAIR OF
HATE-FILLED VOICEMAILS.
TWO OF MANY THAT MICHIGAN
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FRED
UPTON HAS BEEN GETTING RECENTLY.
NOW, BEFORE YOU DO, JUST
CONSIDER THIS.
THEY ARE NOT ABOUT ABORTION OR
RACE OR IMMIGRATION OR MASK
WEARING OR SCHOOLS OR VACCINE
MANDATES OR ANYTHING REALLY
CONTROVERSIAL.
THE OUTPOURING WE'RE GOING TO
PLAY, THE VITRIOL IS ABOUT HIS
VOTE ON A BIPARTISAN BILL ON
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> [ BLEEP ] TRAITOR.
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE.
YOU ARE A [ BLEEP ] TRAITOR.
I HOPE YOU DIE.
I HOPE EVERYBODY IN YOUR
[ BLEEP ] DIES.
YOU PIECE OF [ BLEEP ].
YOU'RE STUPIDER THAN HE IS.
HE CAN'T EVEN COMPLETE A
[ BLEEP ] SENTENCE YOU DUMB
[ BLEEP ] TRAITOR.
PIECE OF [ BLEEP ].
[ BLEEP ].
PIECE OF TRASH.
HOPE YOU DIE.
HOPE YOUR FAMILY DIES.
HOPE EVERYBODY IN YOUR [ BLEEP ]
STAFF DIES.
YOU PIECE OF [ BLEEP ]
[ BLEEP ].
TRAITOR!
>> JUST TO SAY YOUR DAYS ARE
NUMBERED.
YOU ARE A DUMB [ BLEEP ].
>> SO, THOSE THREATS WHICH,
AGAIN, WE SHOULD POINT OUT ARE
ABOUT ROADS AND BRIDGES AND A
BILL THAT, BY THE WAY, SENATE
MINORITY LEADER MITCH McCONNELL,
THE TOP-SENATE REPUBLICAN, IS
NOW CRISSCROSSING HIS STATE
BOASTING ABOUT.
SO THAT'S WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
THAT'S WHERE THE CRAZY IS, TOO.
THE THREATS, BY THE WAY, FOLLOW
THE POSTINGS ONLINE OF ANOTHER
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE.
SHE TWEETED OUT THE NAMES OF THE
REPUBLICAN HOUSE MEMBERS WHO
VOTED FOR THE BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL.
WRITING, QUOTE, THESE ARE THE 13
REPUBLICANS WHO HANDED OVER
THEIR VOTING CARDS TO NANCY
PELOSI TO PASS JOE BIDEN'S
COMMUNIST TAKEOVER OF AMERICA
VIA SO-CALLED INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN A SEPARATE TWEET, WHICH WE
ARE NOT SHOWING YOU, SHE POSTED
THEIR PHONE NUMBERS.
NOW, THE CONGRESSWOMAN, AS YOU
KNOW, A BIG BELIEVER IN THE LIE
OR BIG LIE OR AT LEAST SHE
CLAIMS TO BE.
SHE'S COMPARED MASK MANDATES TO
THE NAZI PERSECUTION OF JEWS AND
THE HOLOCAUST.
SHE'S FLIRTED WITH THE FRAUD
QANON.
SHE IS NOT THE ONE FACING
DISCIPLINE, THOUGH, FROM HER
PARTY FOR EXPOSING FELLOW
REPUBLICANS TO HATE AND PERHAPS
EVEN TO HARM.
AND CONGRESSMAN GOSAR ISN'T EVEN
BEING MILDLY REPRIMANDED BY HIS
PARTY LEADERSHIP FOR HIS
THREATS.
INSTEAD, TO READ FROM A HEADLINE
IN TODAY'S "WASHINGTON POST" AND
I QUOTE, GOP FLOATS PUNISHMENT
FOR ITS 13 APOSTAPOSTATES.
19 SNENATE REPUBLICANS INCLUDIN
MITCH McCONNELL ALSO SUPPORT IT.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING AFTER.
THE PIECE GOES ON TO REPORT SOME
PARTY MEMBERS WANT TO STRIP
THESE 13 REPUBLICANS OF
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS AND QUOTES
FORMER-TRUMP CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS TODAY ENDORSING THE
NOTION.
SAME MARK MEADOWS WHO OF COURSE
HAS BEEN SERVED WITH A PSUBPOEN
TO TESTIFY ABOUT WHAT HE KNEW
ABOUT THE COUP ATTEMPT.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT STORY,
SHORTLY, BECAUSE TEN MORE OF
THOSE DROPPED LATE TODAY.
BUT IF YOU ARE WONDERING WHY
IT'S SUDDENLY A SIN TO SUPPORT
ROADS AND BRIDGES IN YOUR
DISTRICT BUT NO BIG DEAL TO POST
UNHINGED MURDER FANTASY VIDEOS
ABOUT CO-WORKERS AND A SITTING
PRESIDENT, YOU MIGHT WANT TO AT
LEAST ACKNOWLEDGE THE ROLE HIS
OLD BOSS IS PLAYING IN THE
CURRENT CLIMATE.
SOMETHING CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ
CHENEY ADDRESSED HEAD ON THIS
AFTERNOON.
>> WE ARE ALSO CONFRONTING A
DOMESTIC THREAT THAT WE HAVE
NEVER FACED BEFORE.
A FORMER PRESIDENT WHO IS
ATTEMPTING TO UNRAVEL THE
FOUNDATIONS OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
AIDED BY POLITICAL LEADERS WHO
HAVE MADE THEMSELVES WILLING
HOSTAGES TO THIS DANGEROUS AND
IRRATIONAL MAN.
>> SO, SHE, AS YOU KNOW, IS ALSO
BEING TARGETED WITH HATE MAIL
AND THREATS AND POLITICAL
RETRIBUTION ALONG WITH FELLOW
REPUBLICAN ADAM KINZINGER.
THEIR OFFENSE, OF COURSE, IS
WANTING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th.
THAT'S IT.
THAT, TOO, IS NOW CONSIDER ADD
SIN IN THE GOP WHICH ONLY
ENABLES MORE MISBEHAVIOR, MORE